Whaddup, Summerfest! This is Justin Bieber.
You know, it's been really fun and...
...just being able to travel around the world, being able to see a lot of cool things, and...
...just be able to experience new culture and different just like how people are living.
It's always just definitely been a blessing. I've been able to just live my dream...
...and be able to perform for a lot of people, which has been, you know, the best.
It's definite that I get a lot of downtime now that I'm on tour.
Usually, for the past two years, I've been just go, go, go, interviews,...
...just flying everywhere.
Now that I have a bus and, you know, it's a regimented schedule every day, so...
...I'm looking forward to just touring and being able to be on the road with my friends,...
...and just have a good time.
Water gun fights.
Where I'm used to performing in like inside. So, you know, it's different. My tour,...
...we've been doing a lot of like stuff where I'm hanging from like the sky and stuff.
You can't do that outside, obviously, 'cause there's no rig, but,...
...you know, we're gonna have to alter the show a little bit, but it'll be fun.
The fans have been incredible.
I was found on Youtube, so, you know, it was basically fans.
It's like made by fans. It's not branded. You're not, you know, I wasn't made.
It was kind of like I posted videos and just kinda slowly but surely, grew fans,...
...and it got more and more. So, my fans have gotten me to this position and,...
...you know, I owe everything to the fans.